hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are continuing our in
1990 match between kappa blanka and Bora
and so far Bora not doing all that great
losing three to zero to Blanca which is
pretty pretty well interesting as we
already mentioned a few times prior to
this match they played four times
together twice in the 1916 tournament
the the rice Memorial Tournament in New
York and then in the 1918 tournament in
New York yet we covered all four games
ended in a draw
so here capablanca taking the lead 3 to
0 is not something you know people
expect and of course they expect that
capablanca to win the match like we said
it was supposed to be an eight game
match we would be will have to wait and
see but already leading 3 to 0
pretty pretty insane now Kappa Lanka is
great in tournaments but it seems that
in matches he's even better if you
remember his match against Frank James
Marshall or Oregon Swan cores are always
doing awesome in matches so without
further ado let's check out the fourth
game Bora has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 with Knight to f6 by
capablanca and Knight to f3 now and E
six with Bishop to g5 and here
Capablanca goes for the center we have
c5 wealth attacking the center III and
now Knight to c6 here preparing Queen to
b3 Queen to b6 as the bishop is no
longer guarding the B to pawn with a c3
strengthening in the center with Queen
to b6 in here border plays Queen to b3
offering a Queen trade of course white
would enjoy if black captures so black
can strengthen his well at this point
becomes a more central pawn and also he
gets a semi-open fall for his rook and
Capablanca would enjoy a similar thing
if black was able to capture a cap for
some b6 so here of course he doesn't
capture he continues development we have
d5 Knight beat the d2 and here Bishop to
d7 this isn't some long-lost line in
this opening for example there is a game
from 2016 function versus one call that
ended in a draw but in the game nights
to h5 was played here couple one who
continues Bishop to d7 with Bishop to e2
and now seek after sandy
for a cuppa Blanca Blanca trades once in
the center and the Bishop to d6 just
continues development and it's
interesting this position has never
again been been repeated so here as a
move nine we have a game that was never
again repeated I thought you might enjoy
that as well with castles by Bora and h6
now pushing the bishop back here a
couple manga sees that Bora now Castle
kingside with Bishop to h4 and now he
wants to attack with the g5 he wants to
play Knight h5 push f5 and so of course
he first moves the knight and Boris is
this and he's not interested in facing
an attack on the King side so first he
trades Queens with Queen captures eight
captures and out rook Fe one couple
Monica continues his expansion on the
Kings side with g5 Bishop to g3 and here
you might try something like there
should be seven and try and you know her
as this dark square Bishop further but
your white would get a very nice game
after Bishop to c7 so not something you
want to do if you push it a three and a
black will not be able to take advantage
of a semi-open file here on the on the
Queen side so instead after Bishop g3
Capablanca trades with Knight captures H
captures and now Capablanca would want
to play h5 followed by h4 but first he
has to get more protection to the g5
points so f6 prepares h5 but Boris tops
at wave g4 with King to f7 backup of
lanka connecting rooks and now a couple
of Uncas plan is he wants to he wants to
somehow take advantage of his semi open
file on the Queen side and it's a very
instructive how Blanca does it with
Knight the h2 by Bora preparing for this
ePHI of ideas couple Blanca is bound to
play at some point he wants his g4 pawn
protected but also he wants to read
maneuver his night-night f1 followed by
Knight e3 or g3 depending on what black
plays of course we have Knight to a5
Capablanca prepares b5 in the Knight to
c4 c4 is an excellent outpost for the
night and of course if you prevented
with b3 you are creating more weaknesses
on the quick on the queenside
Knight hf1 and border continues with
this plan and now b5 creating a very
nice
outpost on c4 with a three and now just
94 so here if you don't want to capture
and c4 you have to do something about
this backward spawn it's not a backward
spawn yet but you kind of have to do
something about it if you just defend it
with a rook it's well it will be a very
passive rook for quite some time
so here Bora decides to trade it with
Knight captures on c4 b captors and c4
now definitely creating a backward spawn
here and now Coco bonkers plant is how
to utilize this semi open a file to the
best of his abilities he's gonna go okay
six rook b6 pressure the b2 pawn and
then bring the other rook over here and
then create a double threat along the B
file so nice the e3 first you you don't
you can go something like 90 G three it
would just get I mean tripled pawns
there's no a reason for doing this so 93
that's a very nice outpost for the night
look the a 6 cup of bunker continues
with the plan we've just mentioned g3
and now rook the b6 and here rook to a2
kosach is preparing to defend the B to
pawn with rook to e8 and now comes
Bishop to f3 getting you know getting
the bishop out of D 2 square you want to
play rook to eat you to guard the b2
point you don't want to guard it this
way because then you'd have some Bishop
captures on a3 issues and so on so rook
to a5 capablanca is now ready to bring
the auto rook here as well and just pink
the g2 improving the position of the
King rook a b5 now threatening to
capture and like we said you don't want
to play something like rugby one then
you get in a lot of trouble so look to
e2 and here the pawn is defended and
it's not all that clear how to continue
the game from here but Capablanca finds
a very nice idea so feel free to even
pause the video here and try to you know
bring more pressure to the B file while
I give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
finder of plants on a Sunday and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy show
Bishop t8l lovely move even
looking to g7 was also great doesn't
matter if you start with Bishop to eight
or King to g7 but the idea is you want
to bring your brush up to g6 and then
over to be one to force this route back
and then you're just gonna capture on b2
seems like a very simple idea when you
see it of course so postage has to
figure out how to prevent this first he
plays rook to d2 he finds a way with
King to g7 making room for the bishop
here on g6 and now well you can play
Knight d1 to defend this pawn here then
your knight is stuck there your rook is
gonna be stuck on a to not not something
you want to play you're already down
three points in this match you don't
want to play another passive position
against capablanca so Costas tries an
active plan Bishop to d1 now he's gonna
meet Bishop to g6 with Bishop to a four
force this rook away from the B file
Capablanca goes push up to g6 with bush
up to a four now forcing the rook back
we have route 85 and now Bishop the c2
just offering a trade and here it's very
interesting Capablanca is already up
three points in the match he has the
black pieces
capablanca doesn't even a repeat rook to
b5 just to check if cost each will
repeat bishop today for he was for a
trade without even checking this option
Bishop captures on c2 with rook captures
and C - and now King to g6 we've looked
back to E - and now rook a to b v again
pressuring the b2 pawn and even though
Kevon cos rooks are much more active
than Boris rooks unless they can
actually do something along the B file
they're not really all that more active
so first night to d1 cause ditional
defends the pawn with the knight and the
rook and he wants to get this rook into
the game via some nice maneuvering
Bishop to f8 by Capablanca now comes
rook to a 1 kappa blanka checking to see
what Boris plan is with h5 and now f3h
garrison g4 with F captors and g4 and
now f5g captures on f5 with it captures
and now just look to see one continuing
with the plan we've mentioned and now
rook to f6 preparing to pusher on the F
file with rooks
the c2 and now comes Bishop to d6 by
kappa blanka with rook to e8 trying to
grab hold of the back rank but
Capablanca pushes the rug back King to
f7 and here you don't really gain
anything by remaining on the under last
rank so here he just brings it back rook
to e1 and now f4 as planned here of
course this has to decide does he want
to trade or push he decides it's better
to push so g4 with f3 with check King to
f2 and now comes a very nice move how do
you activate the rooks and also keep
your pawn here it's not possible but
Capablanca finds a very interesting idea
and that is rook to h6 and now what do
you do here obviously the threat is the
rook h2 you're gonna lose it rook here
you have to do something about it now
how do you do it well if you play
something like Knights the e3 which
seems like it finishes the job I mean it
does the job nicely add the rook is
defended you're threatening to capture
the pawn here the idea is just rook h3
you just defend the pawn and now white
will not have all that many moves let's
say rook g1 you're just gonna go Bishop
to f4 so what do you do here
rook b1 you have to play something you
don't really have a lot of moves King f8
rook the g1 if you repeat rook to g1
you're gonna lose the game but you don't
have any active moves if cleric do you
want you're gonna get rook h2 check King
captures on f3 and just rock h3 check
and now you lose the night so not
possible so here although 93 seems like
it covers everything it's really just a
losing move so here ghosty just captures
on f3 we have look to h3 check King as
the Bishop guards this diagonal so you
don't really have a lot of choice here
kingi - and now troop to h2 check and
now you can't move the King otherwise
you lose the rook here so nice to f2 and
here a couple Blanca goes to Bishop to
g3 so coupling has sacrificed a point
for activity and hostage has to decide
how to defend it now how do you defend
this position I'll again I'll give you a
second to figure it out while pausing
the video as it also is a very nice idea
so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the best defensive idea for
white here for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as you are
an excellent defender so if you found
King to f1 that's the exact move you
have to find this is the the proper way
to defend it now both the rook and King
are defending it and now capablanca
would probably have to go to rook
captures rook captures captures captures
and you will lose this pawn but after
King f1 and rugby 3 which attacks both
of these pawns white will also have
rookie 5 attacking both of these pawns
most likely the game will end in a draw
but I mean who knows but it should but
after Bishop to g3 border plate rook to
f1 and it seems like a very nice idea
you're defending the knight you're also
ready to move your king and then you
also have some nasty discoveries as
capablanca zinc is also on f7 but this
now doesn't work and here is where the
title of the video comes into
interaction but it's so hard to imagine
how this is even possible so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the only winning move for kappa blanka
in this position it's really just a real
Sunday beauty while I give you a couple
of seconds for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations you are an
in-game master and it means that you
were definitely you know studying the
endgame and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy show the idea is rook b6
with the plan of Rupe to f6 now how does
this work well first you have to decide
how you're gonna defend your night is
already attacked twice your king is I
mean the knight is pinned you cannot
move it if ruk f6 comes it's gonna be
attacked three times so how do you
defend well there aren't all that many
great options you could try pink to d1
and you could try King to f3 so let's
just check King d1 if King do you want
then after loop to f6 you have to play
King a 1 or you're just gonna lose the
night here but now the problem is you're
pinned the knight can't move and the
white the white can't really move any of
the pieces so here a couple on has a
plan of winning the game is rather
simple you just bring the King over to
the Queen side and trade all the pieces
and the white is helpless to stop it
just King b7 you don't have any good
moves you can play rookie to check King
b6 you can just move the room back and
now let's say after rook to f4 you can
even threaten to win the pawn here
rookie to white can just repeat moves
Bishop h4 rug d2 now you can capture the
pawn here as the knight is pinned still
cannot capture
kingi - you know on pin but just rookie
for check you have to go back rook f4
again pressure the night here King e1
and now you can either just bring the
King over to the Queen side and then
trade everything on f2 or even better
you can just push g4 you're gonna play
g3 and it's game over white doesn't have
a move
you're gonna play g3 and now either you
lose material here or you're gonna ID
one and now just this check and enter
the game for white so Kingdom one not a
possibility so what she decides for King
to f3 so what is Capablanca play here
first his Bishop is under attack
okay roof to f6 not possible because
King captures Bishop first couple Blanca
moves it Bishop to h4 and now we have
looked to e - and it seems like a much
better plan now rather than having your
King Khan II one where the knight is
pinned why not just have it here you're
gonna move it to the e3 and everything
is protected or is it here a couple
bunker continues rook f6 check with King
to e3 and now comes b5 and here white
faces a similar problem he can't really
move all that many pieces here cos which
repeats Luke D to come a blanket just
goes King g7 and again here it's
interesting Kostich played before but he
didn't play b4 because he made a blunder
or something he played before because
there's no move white can make it's
really just a monster - swung like the
title suggests because here you can't
move anything because now even though
your King isn't here and the night isn't
pin you still can't move the night
because the rook on f1 is undefended so
you could just move the rook back and
forth let's say Roxy - but now you get
Bishop g3 and after rookie - you're just
gonna get King d7 and now your plan is
to bring your King over to b3 trade
everything on
- and it's game over so we can just you
know show it let's say Roxy - you're
gonna go Kings e6 rook e - King to b6
you can't go Rudy - Bishop f4 check
would win it so white can just repeat
let's taking a five you can go King ee -
now you can go King a for Roxy - King b3
now you force the route back look - E -
and now no reason to wait any longer you
can just trade everything captures rook
captures rook captures rook captures
Bishop captures with check captures
captures and you're just gonna win both
of these pawns well all three of them
and then just push your remaining points
for a win
white is help us to do anything the the
points prevent the King from even
approaching them so it's just completely
winning a endgame so after King g7
hostage didn't find any any anything
better he just played b4 allows this
capture on pass on we have C capture son
b3 and now he plays Knight to d3 okay
the the pawn all captured on poisson so
he can play 93 but it doesn't work of
course you don't want to capture now on
f1 because rook captures on h2 here
capablanca just played rook captures on
d2 and here after king capture son b2 it
was in this position that boar accosted
resigns in the game as well there is
there's really nothing to do here I mean
even even if you don't capture it if you
play something like rook captures here
first couple Blanca will first capture
the night with check and then after King
captures your capture here and you have
a Bishop White has no pieces of course
it's completely winning yeah now after
this King captures on d2 of course is
resigned and Capablanca is now 4 to 0
which is really amazing if you consider
how how strong cost which was especially
if you've been following the coverage of
the 1918 tournament in New York really
really impressive player and losing for
2-0 against Capablanca is not something
anyone expected so we're gonna be
continuing this match although like I
said it will not be 80 games as it
should so we will be finishing this
match tomorrow and then we are going
straight into the match
what's a championship match with
Emmanuel asker so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank sang Suman Andrew Young Tyrus
cardiac franco brainy and Fabian use for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - my previous videos here I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the capablanca saga checking
up in your suggestions and you know the
usual I think oh I will see soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday